il n'est jamais trop tard pour dire sa
vérité c'est ce que doit penser georges
alain qui 18 ans après son élimination
de l'émission star academy crie au
complot si vous regardiez la télévision
en 2002 vous vous souvenez certainement
de ce candidat culte du télé crochet de
tf1 qui s'était différencier par son
rythme lent et son personnage un peu
perché
[Musique]
et
il vaut mieux
aujourd'hui le candidat a décidé de
lâcher ce qu'il avait depuis presque
deux décennies sur le coeur en
expliquant que la star ac était truqué
éliminé aux portes de la demi finale
face à houcine c'est hocine qui est le
candidat déchu confie aujourd'hui au
parisien qu'il n'aurait jamais dû
quitter l'aventuré
maintenant je peux l'avouer tout était
truqué j'avais découvert que c'est moi
et emma daumas qui devions aller en
finale c'était décidé avant même
l'émission visiblement fâché d'apprendre
qu'il était finaliste georges alain
serait alors devenue incontrôlable
j'ai pété les plombs et les producteurs
ont organisé mon élimination en demi
finale car je les menaçait de tout
balancer mon problème c'est que j'étais
plus vieux que les autres candidats et
que j'avais compris les rouages
mais ses déclarations même 18 ans plus
tard interroge alors la star academy
truqués choquer ou pas choquer
[Applaudissements]
voilà de la star academy 2 merci aussi
une d'être avec nous merci à vous alors
j'estime qu'on n'a pas eu le temps
d'équiper qu'on va équiper là tout de
suite
alors c'est donc dans cette interview au
parisien que georges alain mois genre
jarnac que je kiffais dans la star
academy
je vous dis tout de suite est restée à
la loi nathalie andré qui était la
programmatrice de la star academy puis
la directrice tort de la saison 3 a
posté sur twitter tu en manque de
notoriété mon petit chat pourtant avec
ta voix tu aurais dû gagner point
d'interrogation
en attendant sans la star academy tu
seras encore chez toi et non à canal+ ce
qui était truqué c'est sûr c'est qu'elle
tente jaune ne voulait pas chanter avec
toi hashtag georges-alain natalité est
une fille tu va nous raconter tout ça
apparemment nathalie andré a été vénéré
ouf
alors on va voir déjà la première fois
qu'on avait vu georges alain c'était le
31 août 2002 c'était il ya 18 ans et
vous avez vraiment nous expliquer s'il
ya eu tricherie ou par garde voici la
nouvelle promotion de la star academy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je le mets
lui
il est timide thao gardons georges avant
[Applaudissements]
chanel où les à coups de trucage de
trucs ray ici les loups alors donc
georges alain le tube de la saison 2
c'était paris satino black blocs et lino
regarder le gars était très frais me
regarde
[Musique]
jean blanc rouge et noir danse avec le
reflet du miroir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vers des combats y aménager leur fin
merci georges alain c'est un peu le bad
boy de la saison 2 mai et franchement il
ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de rigolade avec
lui alors voir sa prestation sur serre
est sûr c'est qu'on fait des lacets
alors censé resserrer le sucre chante
apparaît évident
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
vomir
[Applaudissements]
alors parce que nathalie andré donc là
la patronne de la cinquantaine d'entre
elles étaient directement sur la deux
mains elle lui a dit qu'il chantait mal
qui l'aurait jamais gagné et georges a
là aussi c'était le blagueur un jour le
gars voulu faire peur à ses potes au
château vous allez voir patxi a eu un
réflexe de ouf pas de physique chimie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[ __ ] beaucoup jouent donc la star
academy je suis un truc est ce que vous
êtes choqués ou pas choqué y avait des
immenses stars sur le plateau de la star
ac' les loups un journal mariah carey
est fade georges halak avait refusé de
chanter que la compagnie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
ce
[Musique]
bonjour
parmi eux
[Musique]
on va te l'expliquer castaldi des
directeurs oui c'est en fait j'en ai
alors ses pouvoirs premièrement on est
en 2002 donc c'est la deuxième saison et
avançait de ce programme là il ya eu
effectivement love story et la
productrice de l'émission de galaxies de
l'académie c'est alexia laroche joubert
qui avait dit clairement à l'époque je
ne fais pas une émission de chansons
finition de t d alan était donc or il
faut savoir que les finales de la star
ac' totaliser jusqu'à de votre choix
entre un et deux millions d'euros
d'euros c'est vrai ça c'est très
important donc c'est vrai qu'ils vont à
cette époque là on fait plus de la télé
réalité que de la queue que la chanson
mais ce qui est vrai jusqu'en 2005 où
2004 ne s'est plus l'année umaga
léveillée a ont gagné la star academy
c'est vrai que les votes on pouvait les
fermer quand on vous dit quand on
voulait moi je les ai vécu puisque moi
sur le loft 2 il voulait absolument je
l' ai découvert à l'antenne et en direct
il voulait absolument que la candidate
qui étaient là la fille de forain soit
sauvé et ils ont coupé des votes ces
abrutis nylon plus de couper à 21h15 en
mettant le disque les votes sont clos
moi j'ai des copains qui m'ont appelé
ils m'ont dit qu'est ce qui se passe non
on peut plus bien sûr on peut plus voter
donc debout et un disque il ya trop
d'appels
il vomit indices qui dit votre ferme et
donc ensuite ça a commencé un petit peu
à bas bruit c'est dans les rares et ils
ont maintenant mimiques une règle c'est
que le huissier était contrôlé nous non
seulement l'ouverture des votes mais la
sphère voitures des votes ce rsa
effectivement dès qu'on a pu contrôler
quand on ouvrait quand on ferme et on
eut il se retrouve avec mag et vallées
qui était très sympathique mais qui ne
voulait absolument pas parce que comme
gagnante je rappelle qu'à l'époque quand
même à la star ac 1 million d'euros pour
le vainqueur
c'est un million ne sont autres sur
notre bouche ans j'en ai alors c'est
magali vaé qui avait gagné c'est pas du
tout alemanno de faire un titre sur elle
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que dans les
rayons de tf1 tout lespade toute
l'espèce je me disais et et patrons à
l'épaule universal qui était pascal
mecque des hélicoptères qu'on va virer
magali et ils n'ont jamais allé chez les
verrez donc c'est vrai qu'à cette époque
là et on s'émeut ce qu'il voulait
l'envoyer d'or et après ils pas vous
mentir sur les sur la façon de faire et
magnéto chaque semaine est aussi une de
ces l'émail et où tous les jours vous
pouvez orienter plus pour l'un des
sahraouis effectivement si vous voulez
qu'un candidat soit georges alain que
dit georges alain gilles lors georges
alain lui il dit que c'était truqué
parce que emma daumas et lui devaient
aller dès le début de l'aventuré en
finale aller je voudrais balayé un
argument balayé qui est le dire que
georges à la soif de notoriété pas du
tout il commet tranquillement ses
matches du championnat turc
il est comment très bien j'ai eu la
personne qui commente avec lui qui m'a
dit mais georges hardy ou absolument
mettre dans la lumière bien sûr on l'a
interrogé y répond donc tout ce qu'il
dit est vrai des puissants vous êtes
gênés vous interrompez avec moi ça
marche pas je ne s'avance pas beaucoup
en fait lui on l'interrogé il dit la
vérité pourquoi il n'a pas dire non mais
parce qu'on lui a pas demandé au p là
aussi mme cayla cible déjà si on fait
qu'on a invité les soutiens mais voilà
déjà ça c'est la règle d'or ou s'il dit
non la vérité est ce que tu as vu des
magouilles dans la star ac oui ou non
ou tu nous dis non 0 magouilles on s'en
met plein les fouilles se croit déjà oui
aussi al'annonce de cet article qui est
paru aujourd'hui tu es resté potec
georges lampin ça fait longtemps qu'on
ne s'est pas vu d'accord on fait on se
fait des réunions repas avec tout
évènement c'est-à-dire des penseurs et
des nouveaux accords je rencontrerai ça
s'appelle quoi je vais présenter avoir
un seul enfant de toi
et on se revoit tous alors c'est vrai
que georges alain est moins présent ou
alors on se rate sur ces rendez vous
après mon aventure que j'ai vécu j'ai
vécu moi c'était comme une grande
colonie de vacances donc si vous voulez
c'est vrai que quand on est sorti ça a
été la folie à aucun moment donné moi je
me suis mis en face de la télé chez mes
parents me disant bon alors on va re
visionner puis eux
alors moi pour le coup les histoires de
2,2 quotidienne qui était plus et
diriger les mâles et honnêtement je ne
sais pas j'ai pas regardé
tu crois ce que dit georges ah non pas
moi je trouve ça dingue parce que la
partie comme ça mais pas du tout
jean-michel à mais comment ne pas croire
georges à main
quel intérêt il à dire ça il était à
l'intérieur il est où on parle dont
parlera espère que oui les laves études
de latin l'histoire et nous on en train
de dire non il arrive qu'une avec des
gens de la star ac mais d'aller en des
gels adore voilà bah c'est bien le dire
ah bon vraiment qu'elle adore c'est une
femme extraordinaire
on l'a beaucoup et c'est parce que je
laime que je que je ne peux pas imaginer
une demi seconde que ce soit risqué
parce que nathalie c'est lui fit
vraiment droite par ailleurs en revanche
ce que dit benjamin sur le fait que oui
les mines et des magnétos qu'on pouvait
orienter c'est à dire que si on a un
candidat que ça et qu'il ya les votes
vous qu'avant non mais les hôtes ont
évidemment que c'est sûr ça c'est sûr et
après je crois alors pour le coup je
crois pas du tout c'est bien possible
que dès le début et qui commencent les
niches en alsace est proposée en
revanche le journal a écrit mais alors
ils sont pascal qui m'écrit qui me dit
je suis un provocateur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toujours parce qu'abidjan doit d'abord
jean pascal filippi pourquoi il attend
18 heures challenge alors on la saison
pascal aussi des formidables la 1000ème
la corvée et je passe que par l éthique
comme sarah abitbol qui parle avant
vous y croyez moi c'est à ceux
d'histoire mais dis moi non pas du tout
a dit jean pascal qui m'appelle hamas et
bien oui bonjour pascal sa maman chérie
ne sait pas vraiment quand il avait deux
ans ouais d'accord donc tunique c'est
une connerie donc tout ça peut-être
parce qu'il n'a pas réussi
toutefois grâce à ce qu'il faudrait un
petit peu dans mon sac est donc claire
de ce qu'il est permis d'avancer et
bavois la balle orange en cascade toi
t'as jamais vu aucune magouille dans
l'astarac sans aucune aucune je sais on
a vu quand je sais que je sais que ce
qu'on m'a dit moi de ce qu'on m'a dit on
avait vraiment des magouilles que sur
love story sur six chrétiens sur ses
craintes aurait déclaré tout sourire
parce qu'il paraît qu'ils avaient
animateurs qui voyait rien donc il
pouvait faire
voilà c'est ça va vite on avait parlé
lors jean-pascal hôtel fort bien de voir
flotter comme on attendait dans sa part
avancé eux c'est nolwenn leroy et si on
veut être complètement c'est à dire que
j'irais même jusqu'à dire que ça serait
une faute professionnelle de ne pas
magouille et ce genre d'émission parce
qu'il s'est mis son je vous dis la
vérité
- l'âge dit tout c'est vrai que dans
l'astarac on connaît tous cette anecdote
ou universal dont la wii il avait dit
mais universal devait vendre des disques
après avec les rieurs et je vous le dis
il voulait tout faire pour que magalie
vaé sans faire ça c'est vrai il sachez
que le producteur de la star academy
toutes les semaines disait que malraux
par la gagne elle encore été sauvé leur
épicerie et il paraît que le patron
d'universal époque elle dit comment
voulez que je vende des discrets voilà
comment je récupère mon millions d'euros
il voulait absolument qu'elle sorte mais
elle n'est jamais sortie magali à la
gagner et bravo à magalas voilà qui a
été oui aussi moi je pense que le public
vote et je pense que même si les
magnétos de temps en temps soit orientée
orientez vous avez tant finale oui
j'étais en finale perdue contre nolwenn
absolument moi j'ai vraiment vécu le
truc à fond on parle de magali magali un
public qui a voté pour elle et un public
il a soutenu ce public là
potentiellement achètent des disques ce
public-là va voir des concerts parce que
magali fait encore des gars la nation et
elles remplissent les salles avec son
comparse les téléspectateurs sur la star
academy on va passer à l'autre sujet les
chéris 62 ans donc les gens poursuit-il
ouais pas vraiment mais bon je vous dis
cette histoire il faut choquer que c'est
pas truqué ses membres et à angers mais
bon on sait que les émissions où il ya
des belles
je n'aime pas que la voilà je vous dis m
étais une personne lui faire c'est un
scandale the way voilà ce qu'ont
d'ailleurs j'ai quand même très forte
émotion ranger si tu demandes aux gens
de pds il a raison voilà la raison c'est
savoir qu'est ce que dit raymond là les
mecs n'ont pas idée sms ils ont pas
envie que ça arrange et bien sûr qu'on
peut dire voici millions d'appels 1 sur
le loft jean jacques attali le sachet
prenez un euro par appel ça pour faire
ouvrir les yeux ce coup